lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
encontrar el área de este triángulo
verde si te sientes inspirado y ojalá
que si te sientes inspirado encuentra
esta área por tu cuenta y bueno siempre
que quiero calcular el área de cualquier
triángulo me acuerdo de una fórmula que
dice que el área de un triángulo la
podemos sacar si conocemos la base y la
altura del triángulo y lo único que
tenemos que hacer es multiplicar estas
dos longitudes entre sí
por un medio entonces si por ejemplo
tenemos un triángulo así
donde este lado de aquí vamos a decir
que es la base y mi bebé y también
sabemos cuál es la altura de este
triángulo ok esta línea de aquí mide h
que es la altura aunque tenemos aquí la
altura y la base entonces para sacar el
área de este triángulo tenemos que
multiplicar base por altura por un medio
y listo
y también podemos calcular el área de
triángulos un poco más extraños por
ejemplo si tenemos un triángulo como
éste
en este lado de aquí es la base y mi
bebé y la altura pues para sacar la
altura nos colocamos en este punto y
dejamos caer un peso y esta longitud de
aquí es la altura aunque ya no está
adentro del triángulo como en este
triángulo pero sigue siendo la altura y
es perpendicular a la base y el área de
este triángulo sigue siendo base por
altura por un medio gay pase por altura
por un medio ahora cómo le vamos a hacer
para aplicar esta fórmula para sacar el
área de este triángulo mongay porque
aquí este triángulo en esta cuadrícula
está como chueco todos los lados de este
triángulo tienen un ángulo con la
cuadrícula y por lo tanto no están nada
fáciles saber cuál es la base y la
altura sin embargo hay varias formas de
solucionar este problema y una de ellas
que es la primera que vamos a ver es
dividir a este triángulo
tintos triángulos cuya base y altura sea
súper fácil de encontrar
ok voy a escoger este punto y este punto
y poner una línea de aquí para acá
porque esta línea divide al triángulo
verde el triángulo grandote del que
queremos sacar el área en dos triángulos
muy padres por crear y lo divide en este
triángulo que estoy colorea 9 azul y
este otro triángulo de aquí aunque pero
este triángulo coloreado de azul ya es
muy fácil sacar cuál es la base y cuál
es la altura gay aunque bueno aquí voy a
hacer un truco vamos a verlo como si
estuviera rotado 90 grados ok la base va
a ser esta de aquí que como podemos ver
mide 12 3 cuadritos aquí entonces
tenemos una base
3 cuadritos y entonces con esa rotación
la altura es esta de aquí y la altura de
este triángulo es 4 y por lo tanto el
área de todo este triángulo coloreado de
azul es un medio por la base que es un 3
por la altura que es un 4 aunque o sea
que tiene un área de 6 y bueno podemos
hacer exactamente lo mismo con este
triángulo de aquí
ok podemos verlo como si lo hubiéramos
rotado 90 grados y este lado de aquí
ahora va a ser la base entonces la base
de este triángulo mide 3 y si esta es la
base entonces
la altura es esta línea de aquí que mide
2 cuadritos y entonces cuál es el área
de este triángulo de aquí pues el área
es un medio por la base por la altura
aunque hay base y altura un medio por 2
es 1 por 3 así es que el área de ese
triángulo straits y cuál va a ser el
área total de todo el triángulo verde
pues va a ser 3 que es el área de este
triángulo más 6 que es el área de este
otro triángulo entonces el área total
área es igual a 9 y esta es una forma de
hacerlo tomamos el triángulo verde y lo
dividimos en dos triángulos cuya base y
altura era muy fácil de encontrar y nada
más sumamos las áreas ok ahora esa no es
la única forma de encontrar el área del
triángulo verde hay muchísimas y la que
vamos a ver ahorita es podríamos decir
que es un poco más truculenta o tal vez
podríamos decir que se requiere un poco
más de imaginación es más original pero
déjame primero limpio todo lo que hemos
escrito aquí
y la otra forma de sacar el área de este
triángulo que vamos a ver
consiste en imaginarnos un rectángulo
que rodea a este triángulo y para eso
empezamos pintando esta línea de aquí
y me imagino que mientras estoy
dibujando este rectángulo tú ya estás
pensando en muchas cosas que nos podrían
ayudar a encontrar el área ok en
especial porque una vez que ya dibujamos
el rectángulo podemos observar que está
compuesto por el triángulo del cual
queremos conocer el área más otros tres
triángulos rectángulos tenemos este
triángulo rectángulo que estoy
coloreando de amarillo tenemos y tenemos
este triángulo rectángulo que estoy
coloreando de morado y tenemos este
triángulo rectángulo que estoy
coloreando de azul
y esto está súper padre porque aquí
podemos encontrar muy fácilmente el área
de este rectángulo que es 4 x
o sea 24 y si al área del rectángulo le
restamos el área de estos triángulos
rectángulos si lo restamos el área del
triángulo morado y le restamos el área
del triángulo azul y le restamos el área
del triángulo amarillo lo que nos va a
quedar es el área del triángulo verde
que es el área que queremos entonces
pues hagamos justo eso porque tenemos
aquí este rectángulo que mide 24 y le
queremos restar el área de este
triángulo morado y eso es un medio de la
base por la altura aunque ya lo estamos
viendo otra vez rotado tiene una base de
3 cuadritos y tiene una altura
6 cuadritos entonces queremos restar un
medio por 3 por 6 y también queremos
restar el área del triángulo azul que
tiene una base de 4 cuadritos y una
altura de un cuadrito entonces tiene un
área de un medio por 4 por 1 y
finalmente nada más nos falta restar el
área del triángulo amarillo lo que hay
que tener una base de 2 cuadritos y una
altura de 4 cuadritos entonces su área
es un medio por 2 x 4 y que es lo que
tenemos aquí pues tenemos un medio por 3
por 6
eso es 3 por 3 que es 9 aquí tenemos un
medio por 4 x 1 eso es 2
y finalmente un medio por dos por cuatro
que es un 4 así es que tenemos 24 menos
9 menos 2 y menos 4 y eso a ver 24 menos
eso es 15 menos 2 13 y menos 4 es un 9
aunque nos dio un área igual a 9
así es que pues acabamos de terminar de
ver otra forma de encontrar el área de
este triángulo